what happens is
um universities
from the best to the worst from the most
famous to the least well-known
have been taken over by administrators
administrators do not really subsume
academic values they know nothing about
the Constitution they know nothing about
Free Speech they do nothing about
academic freedom they feel that their
job is to keep a water
and so they develop speech codes
kangaroo courts to enforce the speech
codes
and these are very dire developments I
wrote about them in the shadow
University in 98.
um and try to deal with them in 1999
when I started fire code started fire
and um
uh I would fire the reason I'm running
currently for the Harvard Board of
overseers is what I'd like to do is
convince the Harvard Corporation the
so-called president and fellows of
Harvard College the chief governing
board of the University with the real
power
the board of overseas is a secondary
body but quite influential
uh to fire 95 of the administrators
it would have a salutary effect on the
academics of the University we'd have a
salutary effect on free speech and
academic freedom it would cut tuitions
by about 40 percent
um and it would create a whole different
atmosphere on the campus and the same
set of MIT or any other place
um I think administrators are a uh a a
very uh
bad uh influence on American higher
education can you sort of elaborate uh
the intuition why this
thing that you call administrative bloat
is such a bad thing for a university
well first of all just in terms of the
the cost of yeah maintaining there are
more administrators in America education
than they were faculty members
the course is enormous number two
they are inimical to the uh the the
teaching Enterprise and and they feel
that their job is to control things to
make sure there are no problems that
nobody's feelings are hurt
um uh being called you know be before I
a Dean because you said something
um that insulted somebody is something
that shouldn't happen in American higher
education yet it happens because you
have these administrators who think it's
their job
to protect people from being insulted
you you insult a black student you
insult a woman
um there's a disciplinary hearing but
there shouldn't be
um
black people uh are accustomed to being
insulted Jews are cousins cousins being
women or cousins being solid and it's
very good to know who doesn't like you
it's useful it is very you it's
essential information to know who
doesn't like you if everybody is forced
to say I love you and nobody can say I
hate you you get a false view of what
life is all about outside of the
University outside the university I mean
you do graduate eventually
and that's ultimately the mission of the
university is to prepare you to make you
into a great human being into a great
leader that can take on the problems of
the world correct and you don't do it by
by treating you like like a little
flower but what role does the University
have to protect students to women
African-Americans
anybody Jews anybody who gets killed you
could be a victim of hate speech they
they protect you from physical assault
if somebody physically assaults you
then they um they get punished but they
shouldn't and so they shouldn't protect
you against insult
because that is a violation of academic
freedom the freedom of the insulter to
insult you and also as I said it's very
useful to know who doesn't like you it's
useful for the so-called victim I think
is to said I want to know who doesn't
like me it's as important to me as
knowing who who likes me but do you also
believe in this open uh space of
discourse that the insulter will
eventually lose
I think that's true I think of the
insult or eventually
will wear out his or her welcome
um I do but I I like to know who the
insult is over
because it gives you a deeper
understanding of human nature yeah and
and usually by the way my experience has
been that the insulters have generally
not been as smart as the people they've
insulted yeah and that's probably one of
the reasons they insult them because
they're if they feel inferior yeah I
mean I'm not trying to be a a a
psychoanalyst here but a lot of the
people who were the haters are pretty
low down in the intellectual scale
anyway 95 of administration you would
fire your calling to fire
95 of the administration people should
know I think
people that don't really think about the
structure the way the universities work
are not
familiar I think with the fact that
Administration there's a huge bloat of
administration you know when you think
about what makes a great University it's
about the students it's about the
faculty it's about the people that do
research if it's a research University
they don't think about the bureaucracy
of meetings and committees and rules and
paperwork and all that and all the
people that are involved with pushing
that kind of paper and there's a huge
cost to that but it also slows down and
suppresses the the beautiful variety
that makes the university great which is
the teaching the Student Life the
protests the the the
um the clubs all the fun that you can
have at University all the very kind of
exploration which you can't really do
once you graduate correct it's the place
the university is a place to really
explore
in every single way
so let me just talk about this important
thing because uh I'm very fortunate to
have contacted you
almost by accident in a very important
moment in your life you're running for
the Harvard Board of overseers uh what
is this board how much power does it
have
uh and what would you do if elected okay
first of all I have a I have a
prediction yes that in about five years
they're gonna probably change the name
because overseer is reminds people of
the slavery or yes and we're in a such a
politically correct era now that the
English language is being restricted
corrupted is the way I put it because
certain words are uh are forbidden we we
have some problems in this country and I
think part of the problem is the
educational system
has lost a sense of what academic
freedom and Free Speech were all about
and um and and
um I think it's essential that the
educational system begin to take more
seriously what free speech and negative
Freedom really are that's why I'm
running for the Harvard Board of
overseers so let me just link on the
uh the role of the administration in
protecting free speech so what often
happens I think you've written about
this is there's going to be a few
maybe a small number of hypersensitive
students and faculty that protest so how
does Harvard Administration
uh resist the influence of those
hypersensitive protesters in protecting
uh Speech and protecting even hate
speech
Harvard has done fairly well under the
presidency of Lawrence back how
I have had a couple of meetings with
bacow
um I like that cow
I have donated to Harvard a prince of my
life but my late wife took a picture of
Bob Dylan and Alan Ginsburg when the
Rolling Thunder review got to Harvard
Square
and it's a it's sort of an iconic
photograph she called it the music
lesson because it's got Dylan teaching
Ginsburg how to play the guitar
and I donated one of those to Harvard
it's hanging in Backhouse office
he the new president
Claudine gay is not known for respecting
academic freedom and Free Speech people
have said to me well give her a chance
well I'm willing to give her a chance
but she does have a record
and she's a bureaucrat
um I don't think she believes in free
speech and academic freedom I think
she's a progressive not a liberal
um I'm not happy with the the uh the the
the appointment of Claudine gay and it
has made more essential my attempt to
get on the board of overseers
so let's talk about the board of
overseers and uh your run for it the
specifics actually it would be you'd be
nice because I think you're a writing
candidate
and the election is over on May 16th uh
yes and I think there's specifics I'll
probably give them in the intro I'll
give links to people but the specifics
are complicated let me just mention
that you have to be Harvard alumni so
I've graduated from Harvard you have to
in order to run in order to vote in
order to vote and the process I imagine
is not trivial but uh
it this is done online and if you're an
alumni you should have received an email
from a particular email address
harvard.mg
electionservicescorp.com and uh
presumably there's a way to get some
validation number from that email and
then you go online you enter that
validation number and you vote and you
to vote for Harvey you have to enter his
name
correctly Harvey silverglate and spell
it correctly
um obviously I'm imagining this because
I'm MIT not Harvard so I'm imagining the
process is not trivial because you have
to click on things you have to uh
uh sort of follow instructions that are
not uh trivial and uh I'll also provide
an email if the process is painful it
doesn't work for you that you can email
email Harvard and complain I.T help at
harvard.edu and so on I'll provide all
the links but is there something else
you can say about the voting process uh
what you're running on this is my second
run
the first time I got enough signatures
to get on the ballot then the Harvard
Alumni Association sent out a letter
to all living Harvard alums
recommending that they vote for the
officially nominated candidates
that excluded two petition candidates of
whom I was one
and um
I wrote to the Alumni Association and I
said
you have now sent out the curriculum
vitais and the policy positions of all
these officially nominated candidates
there are two petition candidates on the
ballot
I would like to be able to send out my
positions
to the voters
they wrote me back saying our policy is
to only send out the policy positions
and the platforms of officially
nominated candidates can you believe
that
well this is a liberal arts college
right
um from the where from The Clash of
ideas truth emerges well really
this is what I call Harvard's not so
subtle means of candidate suppression
not voter suppression candidate
suppression
and um
everybody can vote but not everybody can
run
it is ill becomes a liberal arts college
where you know the Clash of ideas will
produce the truth will worry about the
class of ideas on the board of overseers
the board of offices is important it
doesn't have the same power and
authority as the Harvard Corporation the
so-called president and fellows of
Harvard College but it's very
influential
and very important and it would be a
great perch for me to try to exert
influence for the University to get back
to where it was before it was taken over
by the administrators well I'm pretty
sure that most of Harvard alumni most
the students currently going to Harvard
most The Faculty at Harvard probably
stand behind that ideas and the ideals
that you stand behind yep the the people
that love Harvard and what it stands for
so yeah the alumni were educated in an
era when these Concepts were taken
seriously and before the
administration's administrators took
over
so I do think if I get my message out
I'm going to win the seat and if I win a
seat I will have a great perch for for
trying to convince the real power that
be which is the Harvard Corporation
to do the things that I'm suggesting you
know get rid of 90 five percent of the
administrators get rid of the speech
codes reduce tuition by 40 percent
all of these salutary benefits
can you imagine if Harvard became the
most affordable college in the United
States
well the affordability is another aspect
but I think before that the just the
freedom of expression freedom of speech
freedom of thought yeah it went to
America's greatest universities I think
is something that everybody would agree
on it would have a it would have a a
tremendous effect on the whole country
and uh is there something to say about
the details of how difficult it is for
alumni to vote without experience with
this you could vote online or you can
vote by paper ballot you can request a
paper ballot
um and all I could say is that the the
hard part is getting the message out
um my name doesn't appear on the ballot
because I couldn't get enough signatures
um well Harvey Harvey silverglate
s-i-l-v-e-r-g-l-a-t you know when my
grandparents arrived from Russia
um the uh the the the name in Russia was
something like zilbrith yeah and the
immigration officer had several choices
he could have said Sylvia gate yeah gate
is a real silver and gate are real
English words yeah he could have said
silver Glade g-l-a-d-e those are real
English words that's how my name is
often the spelled neither Silver Gate or
silver Glade silver Glade is a nonsense
syllable
and why the immigration officer chose to
transliterate
silverglid as silverglade I'll never
understand and it is the cause of
endless mistakes in my name well the the
fundamental absurdity of life
yes is also the source of his Beauty yes
anyway we shall spell it out and we
shall get uh yell loud and wide that
everybody who's ever graduated from
Harvard should vote for you if they
believe in the ideals of the Great
American universities which I think most
people do